[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ليبيا تعاني من طبيعات التغير المناخي
ازاله الغابات ونقص الغطاء النباتي والزحف
العمراني غير المنظم وحفر الابار واستخدام
المياه الجوفيه بطريقه عشوائيه وتلوث
البحار اسهم في زياده خطوره التغير
المناخي ليبيا في هذا المجال لا اعتقد ان
فيه استراتيجيه واضحه لمكافحه التلوث او
في برنامج موعد من قبل الدوله الليبيه في
مكافحه الملوتات وفي مكافحه التصحر في
موجوده مراكز بحثيه ولكن تطبيق عملي لا
اعتقد ان فيه يقول خبراء ان بعض المناطق
على الشواطئ الليبيه مهدده بالغرق في مياه
البحر الزائده الناجمه عن ذوبان ثلوج
القطبين الشمالي والجنوبي اضافه الى ذلك
فان بعض الموانئ عجزت عن استقبال البواخر
بسبب سحب الرمال عليها
احد الاخر منها بالمحاجر والنشاطات
البشريه الغير مقننه يعني زد عن ذلك همم
الموانئ والارصفه اللي بدات تعاني من زحف
الكتبان الرمليه عليها
يحاولوا اعضاء جمعيه اصدقاء الشجره توعيه
المجتمع بانواع النباتات التي تستطيع
مجابهه الظروف المناخيه الصعبه التي تمر
بها ليبيا وبضروره الاكثار من غرسها ان في
المناط الصحراويه انواع الاكاسيا والسدر
المناطق الجبليه مثل الخروب وفي همم
نباتات المدخنه جديده
عليه بعض والمشاريع الزراعيه توقفت تماما
اما نتيجه للتغير المناخي او للاهمال
الاداري والظروف القاهره التي تعيشها
البلاد في احسن فتره انتاجها المشروع
حوالي 75,000 معدل للاكتار اوكي انت هذه
من احسن سنوات ومن ثم بدا التراجع لعده
اسباب من اسباب امكانيات ماليه او وكذلك
عدم توفير القطريات حسب دراسه لمكتب الامم
المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه فان
الذين يعيشون في الظروف هشه المثل ليبيا
يشعرون بتاثيرات التغيير المناخي بشده
فالصراعات المسلحه تدفع الناس الى الخروج
من ديارهم وهذا يعرقل انتاج الاغذيه ويزيد
من حده الامراض وسوء التغذيه ويضعف خدمات
الرعايه الصحيه